SUBCOMMITTEE ON SEXUAL
HARASSMENT PREVENTION AND
RESPONSE.
WE'RE GOING TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM.
SO IF WE CAN PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN HERE
FRIEDMAN HERE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DOLLY HERE SUMMER DAILY HERE
BREA'S HERE REYES HERE WALDRON.
WALDRON HERE SENATOR MITCHELL.
SENATOR MITCHELL HERE SENATOR
BATES.
FULLER BATES HERE SENATOR LEYVA
CENTER LEYVA HERE SENATOR
MORLOCK.
SUTTER MALEK HERE.
WE HAVE.
THANK YOU.
ARE TODAY IS OF THE EIGHT
HEARING.
OF THIS COMMITTEE AND I EXPECTED
TO BE THE LAST OF THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE BEFORE WE SEND A
POWER RECOMMENDED POLICY
FRAMEWORK TO JOINT RULES.
HOPEFULLY FOR ADOPTION OR
MODIFICATION I WANT TO THANK ALL
OF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
YOUR HARD WORK I DON'T THINK WE
HAD ANY ABSENCES IN THIS HEARING.
EVERYBODY WORKED.
A VERY HARD --
VERY COOPERATIVELY IN A VERY
BIPARTISAN MANNER AND I'M VERY
PROUD OF THE FINAL RESULT.
WE MET ON MONDAY TO GO OVER IN
MORE DETAIL THE RECOMMENDED --
FRAMEWORK FOR A NEW SEXUAL
HARASSMENT POLICIES WHICH COVER
EVERYTHING FROM TRAINING TO
REPORTING. TO ADJUDICATION --
ALL THE WAY THROUGH THE PROCESS
MORE MAKING A LOT OF VERY
FUNDAMENTAL CHANGES --
THIS IS THE BEGINNING OF WHAT'S
GOING TO BE WORKING PROGRESS
OVER TIME THAT WE WILL
CONSTANTLY BE REEVALUATING I'M
SURE AND TWEAKING.
A SUIT OUR NEEDS BUT I THINK
THAT WE'RE STARTING WITH A VERY
VERY STRONG OF FRAMEWORK THAT'S
GOING TO MAKE A LOT OF
FUNDAMENTAL CHANGES.
WE HEARD SEVERAL COMMENTS ON
MONDAY AND HAVE CHANGED --
OUR DOCUMENT TO REFLECT AS MANY
OF THOSE COMMENTS I'M JUST GOING --
TO BRIEFLY GO THROUGH THOSE
BEFORE I DO I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
IF MY A VICE CHAIR SENATOR HOLLY
MITCHELL HAS ANY COMMENTS AT
THIS TIME NO [inaudible]
GREAT SO.
THE COMMENTS THAT WE HEARD THAT
WE HAVE MADE --
MODIFICATIONS THE DOCUMENT AND
AND JUST SO EVERYONE KNOWS THERE
ARE TWO DOCUMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
PROVIDED TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE ONE
DOCUMENT WITH THE RED LINE
CHANGES AND ANOTHER DOCUMENT
THAT IS A NOW COMPLETE NEW
DOCUMENT.
AND I'M GOING TO HIGHLIGHT THE
FIVE ITEMS THAT WERE CHANGED.
THEY ARE THE FIRST I HAD TO DO
WITH LOBBYISTS A CONCERN RAISED
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES AND
OTHERS.
WHICH IS TO MAKE THE
RECOMMENDATIONS CLEARER ON THE
AVAILABILITY OF THIS PROCESS TO
A DIRECT THE CLOCK KIND UP OF
LOBBYISTS AND OTHERS AND THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT IS REFLECTED IN
THE DOCUMENT AND WILL BE A
DISCUSSION POINT --
FOR JOINT RULES ON MONDAY AND
SOMETHING THAT WE WILL LOOK AT
FINDING WAYS OF INCORPORATING
INTO OUR POLICY.
AND BY THE WAY BECAUSE I'M GONNA
TAKE THESE ONE AT A TIME IF
ANYBODY HAS A COMMENT ON A
SPECIFIC ITEM.
YOU CAN GO AHEAD AND MAKE IT
BEFORE I MOVE TO THE NEXT ITEM
SO ANY COMMENTS ON THAT ITEM.
OKAY.
THE SECOND I'M A BROUGHT UP
CRIMINAL CASES THAT WE HAVE
CLARIFIED THAT CRIMINAL CONDUCT
WILL BE REFERRED DIRECTLY TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
BUT WE WILL ALSO ALLOW THE
INVESTIGATION TO BE SUSPENDED OR
TO PROCEED DEPEND ON INTERNALLY
AS WELL DEPENDING ON THE
CIRCUMSTANCES.
I'M THE THIRD COMMENT IS ABOUT
PANEL APPOINTMENTS.
WHICH WAS A CONCERN OF TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DOLLY AND
WALDRON AND OTHERS WE'RE GOING
TO CLARIFY THE PANEL APPOINTMENT
PROCESS TO ENSURE THAT THE PANEL
IS NON PARTISAN.
BY REQUESTING THAT THE CHIEF
JUSTICE APPOINT THE MAJORITY OF
THE PANEL MEMBERS AS A MEMBER
DALY.
THANK YOU AND THE FIRST I WOULD
SAY THAT.
IT'S BEEN A REAL PLEASURE --
TO SIT ON THIS COMMITTEE AND TO
BE ABLE TO ENGAGE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES FROM FROM THE SENATE
AND THE ASSEMBLY --
AND I THINK THAT.
AS YOU STATED EARLIER THAT THIS
IS A WORK IN PROGRESS AND WERE
WERE TAKING TO DO --
SOMETHING THAT HASN'T BEEN DONE.
IN THE ASSEMBLY OR THE SENATE
FOR A LONG TIME AND AND BRING --
SHED LIGHT ON ON SOME SITUATIONS
SO I WANT TO COMMEND THIS
COMMITTEE AND AND TO SHOW THE
SERIOUSNESS OF IT --
YOU KNOW WE MISSED A MEETING IN
THAT THAT'S RARE. TO HAPPEN --
IN THIS BUILDING.
SO WITH THIS NUMBER DO WITH THIS
ITEM HERE I WANTED --
TO I HAVE A SUGGESTION AND I AM
BY THE WAY I I I HERE'S WHAT.
MY GOAL AND I TRY --
MONDAY THAT. FOR ME THE GOAL IS
TO MAKE IT AS NONPARTISAN --
AS THE POLICY AS WE CAN GET SO.
I HAVE A SUGGESTION HERE THAT
THAT COME AND I JUST LEARNED --
A FEW MINUTES AGO ABOUT HOW THE
DIFFERENCES OF THE TWO HOUSES
WORK.
WHICH I WASN'T A TOTALLY AWARE
OF SO I WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU
THAT I THINK THAT IT'S
APPROPRIATE THAT [inaudible]
THE IF JUSTICE APPOINT THREE I
THINK THAT'S A GREAT START BUT
OF THE REMAINING.
TWO COM.
THAT EACH HOUSE SO I SAID THIS
IS MY SUGGESTION THAT EACH HOUSE.
BUT USED THE REMAINING ONE SO WE
GET TO A A TOLL OF FIVE AND THAT
THE THE MINORITY LEADER IN THIS
SPEAKER.
WORK TOGETHER ON OUR SIDE TO
POINT OUT AND THE MINORITY
LEADER AND THE PRO TO HIM ON THE
OTHER SIDE.
COME INTO AGREEMENT TO POINT
THAT SO THAT TAKES OUT ALL
PARTISANSHIP --
ON THAT FIVE PERSON PANEL SO
THAT'S WHAT I WOULD SUGGEST BE
THE PROCESS --
MOVING FORWARD SO ON AND SO IN
TODAY'S WORLD IT WOULD BE.
A ANTHONY I AND AND ON THE
SENATE TONY AND PASS.
AND SO THAT WOULD THAT WOULD
THAT MAKE IT THEY COULD WORK
TOGETHER FOUND IN AGREEMENT WITH
THAT APPOINTMENT SO WE GET TO A
REALLY.
A NONPARTISAN --
UP.
COMMITTEE THAT CAN LOOK AT THESE
CASES AND COME UP WITH THAT.
A SO IT AGAIN SO THAT THERE'S NO
WAY THAT IT'S WAITED
BIPARTISANSHIP AT ALL.
THANK YOU FOR THAT EXCELLENT
SUGGESTION --
MOVING ON FOLLOW UP WITH
COMPLAIN TIM TEHAMA ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WALDRON HAD BROUGHT THIS
UP.
AND WE HAVE I CLARIFIED THAT THE
DIRECT VOTE TO DIRECT THE
INDEPENDENT UNIT TO PROVIDE
UPDATES TO THE COMPLAIN SO THAT
THEY UNDERSTAND THAT THE PROCESS
IS ONGOING.
AND THAT IT'S BEING DEALT WITH --
LASTLY MANDATORY REPORTING AGAIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON AND
OTHERS HOME WE'RE GOING TO
CONFORM THE RECOMMENDATION SOME
POLICY TO CLEARLY REQUIRE
SUPERVISORS TO REPORT COMPLAINTS
OF INAPPROPRIATE CONDUCT.
AND OF COURSE WE'RE GOING TO BE
TRAINING THAT ENCOURAGING ALL
EMPLOYEES TO REPORT IF --
HOW INAPPROPRIATE CONDUCT IF
THEY WITNESSES --
AT THE VERY LEAST TO FIND OUT IF
IT'S SOMETHING THAT IS
REPORTABLE SO THAT'S GOING TO BE
AN ONGOING.
TRAINING --
GOAL AS WE WORK WITH OUR
EMPLOYEES --
WITHOUT IT THERE'S NO MORE
COMMENTS ABOUT THE CHANGES.
I'M I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT AND THEN I'LL COME BACK
BUT LET US ALL GO NOW TO OF
SENATOR BATES.
BOTH A FEW AYE TERROR THOUGHT
RIGHT.
THIS IS NOT INCLUDED IN YOUR
CURRENT DOCUMENT AS AN AMENDMENT
IT'S A SUGGESTION THAT WE PUT
FORWARD WHEN WE REACH JOINT
RULES.
IT IT HAS TO DO A SECTION FIVE A
RETAIN HOW SECURITY DETERMINE
APPROPRIATE RESPONSE TO REPORTS.
FAR IN THE LAST LINE ON SECTION
IT SAYS THE CHAIR OF THE
RELEVANT RULES COMMITTEES WHO
WILL RECEIVE A COPY OF EACH
REPORT.
THAT SUGGESTED ONLY TO
INDIVIDUALS ARE GOING TO GET THE
REPORT CANDID THAT PUTS A HUGE
BURDEN ON THE DOWN.
SIDE PERHAPS BEING A PROBLEM.
I HATE TO USE THE WORD ACCUSED
BUT THE PERCEPTION MIGHT BE THAT
THEY COULD BURY A REPORT ON
SOMEONE.
FOLLOWING IN THE SORT OF THE
APPROVAL EASIER A AND SO I'M
SUGGESTING THAT OUT WE ADD WE
STRIKE.
THE LANGUAGE THAT SAYS THE CHAIR
OF THE RELEVANT RULES COMMITTEE
WILL RECEIVE A COPY OF EACH
REPORT AN AD.
IN THE SENATE EACH REPORT SHALL
BE SIMULTANEOUSLY PROVIDED TO
ALL FIVE MEMBERS OF THE RULES
COMMITTEE THAT'S HOW IT OPERATES
ON THE SENATE SIDE.
IN THE SECRETARY OF THE SENATE
IN INDIAN THE ASSEMBLY EACH
REPORT SHALL BE SIMULTANEOUSLY
PROVIDED TO THE CHAIR AND THE
VICE CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY RULES
COMMITTEE.
AND THE ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICER
OF THE ASSEMBLY AND THAT
PROVIDES A BROADER DISTRIBUTION
AND I CHAIRMAN. FOR FREE
CHAIRWOMAN FRIEDMAN HAD ON THE
QUESTION REGARDING BY WOULD THAT
INCLUDE ALL REPORTS EVEN THOSE
WERE THERE WAS JUST AN
INAPPROPRIATE COMMENT THAT
DOESN'T LICENSE.
I THINK WE COULD THINK ABOUT
THAT BETWEEN NOW AND THEY ON IN
AFTER SPUR APPROPRIATE LANGUAGE
THAT ALL CAN KNOW.
MAYBE FACTOR INTO IT THAT'S FINE
BUT I THINK IF I WERE THE PRO
TIM AND I WAS GOING TO BE THE
ONLY ONE THAT GOT THE REPORTED
IF YOU REMEMBER THERE WAS A
LITTLE DUST UP ABOUT THAT
EARLIER.
THAT'S THAT'S NOT A GOOD BURDEN
TO PUT ON THE INDIVIDUALS ON
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SOMETHING.
LIKE THIS THE CULTURE CHANGES IF
THERE'S ANY SORT OF FAVORITISM
OR LACK OF TRANSPARENCY SO I
THINK IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
ADDRESSES BOTH OF THOSE ISSUES
THAT.
WE HAVE SPOKEN ABOUT ON THE
COMMITTEE ARE ALL OVER THE OVER
THE COURSE OF OUR DISCUSSIONS
AND TRANSPARENCY IS IMPORTANT
AND WE WOULD ALL.
YOU KNOW HAVE A COPY AT THE SAME
TIME COUNT OF THE SAME
INFORMATION.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL YES
THANK YOU MISS BATES I
APPRECIATE ON THE PERSPECTIVE IN
THE DRAFT LANGUAGE --
AND I THINK --
AS MY COLLEAGUE JUST MENTION
RECOGNIZE THAT THE THAT THE TO
SENATE RULES COMMITTEE IS REALLY
HAVE DIFFERENT CORE FUNCTIONS
AND OPERATE VERY DIFFERENT WILL
BE IMPORTANT WE MAKE SURE.
THAT THE LANGUAGE JUST APPLIES
TO BOTH --
RULES COMMITTEES APPROPRIATELY
AND IN THAT WE ARE CONTINUE TO
TALK ABOUT THE DETAILS AND TAKE
IT UP ON A MONDAY WHEN THE JOINT
RULES COMMITTEE MADE.
OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M SENATOR MORLOCK.
MADAME CHAIR --
I'VE A LOT OF QUESTIONS BUT I'M
SKINNER DOWN THE THREE HAVE
BECAUSE WE'RE GONNA.
YOU KNOW WE'VE HAD SHORT NOTICE
HE JUST GOT.
THE DRAFT SYSTEM.
CLEARLY JUST FRIDAY --
BUT LOOK AT THIS IS GONNA BE.
BUT IT'S GOING TO THE THREE
QUESTIONS ARE GONNA GET ONCE WE
STEP OUT OF THE ROOM AND WE GET
A REPORTER INTERVIEWS THE FIRST
HIS.
BUT THAT THERE'S A CRITICISM
THAT.
THE POLICY DOESN'T RECOMMEND
CHANGING STATE LAW TO REQUIRE
THAT DOCUMENTS ABOUT THE
LEGISLATURE'S HARASSMENT
ENQUIRIES.
OR FINDINGS BE MADE PUBLIC WHICH
OF MY ANSWER BE.
I WOULD TO SUBMIT OKAY OKAY ALL
A LEAD ON SENATOR MITCHELL A
POEM --
RESPOND FIRST.
BUT THEN THE MORE LACKEY YOU'VE
BEEN EMPLOYER BEFORE AND WE'RE
EMPLOYER NOW AND I THINK --
WHAT WHAT'S BEEN UNIQUE ABOUT
THIS PROCESS FOR ME I THINK I'VE
BEEN --
CERTAINLY THE ONE TO CONSTANTLY
SAY IT IN ALL OF OUR MEETINGS ON
BOTH PUBLICLY AND PRIVATELY THAT
WHERE AN EMPLOYER.
AND WE ARE DEVELOPING A POLICY
TO GOVERN.
OF OUR INTERNAL WORKPLACE
BEHAVIOR.
I THINK THAT WE HAVE STEPPED UP
TO THE PLATE IN A MEANINGFUL WAY.
TO HAVE A PUBLIC PROCESS --
ON IT IN THESE NOW EIGHT
HEARINGS TO HELP DEVELOP THE
PROCESS.
FUNDAMENTALLY IT IS AN H. OUR
POLICY.
AND I KNOW THAT --
IS -- FOR
SOME CHALLENGING IN TERMS OF ON
THIS AND ADESIRE FOR
TRANSPARENCY AND I BELIEVE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THIS PROCESS HAS
BEEN TRANSPARENT.
AND TO THE DEGREE THAT IT IS
APPROPRIATE IN THAT IT IS A EACH
OUR POLICY. FOR A WORKPLACE THE
POLICY WE DEVELOPED HAS BEEN
TRANSPARENT WILL CONTINUE --
TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS TO MAKE IT
POWELL PALATABLE TO US THE
EMPLOYERS.
BUT WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE THAT AS
EMPLOYERS WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO PROTECT THE
PRIVACY OF EMPLOYEES.
AND SO TRANSPARENCY WE TALK THAT
EARLIER HEARING ABOUT SEMANTICS
AND HOW WE CAN KIND OF THROW
WORDS AROUND IN THIS
EXPECTATIONS TRANSPARENCY.
BUT THIS IS AN INTERNAL.
H. OUR POLICY. FOR THE SECOND
QUESTION ME JUST ADD TO THAT IF
I MIGHT -- I
THINK IT'S ALSO WORTH POINTING
OUT THAT THE MODEL THAT WE FACED
A LOT OF THIS POLICY ON AND
WHICH IS THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY'S MODEL.
HAS NO TRANSPARENCY NOTHING IS
DISCLOSED AS FAR AS I KNOW --
TO THE PRESS OR TO OUTSIDE
GROUPS WHETHER IT'S ABOUT --
INVESTIGATIONS OF ELECTED
OFFICIALS OR INTO ANY OF THEIR
INTERNAL STAFF EVEN HIGH LEVEL
STAFF.
WEIRD WE MADE ITS DECISION IN
THIS PANEL TO GO BEYOND THAT.
AND TO DISCLOSE SERIOUS
ALLEGATIONS SUSTAINED
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST MEMBERS AND
SENIOR STAFF --
WHICH IS MORE THAT MANY PUBLIC
PUB MANY PUBLIC AGENCIES ARE
DOING THERE' A VERY LARGE CITY
IN CALIFORNIA THAT WAS ON THE
FRONT PAGE OF THE LA TIMES THIS
WEEK ABOUT.
SEXUAL HARASSMENT ALLEGATIONS IN
VERY HIGH LEVELS OF THEIR CITY
DEPARTMENT AND THEY SAID WE ARE
GOING TO SAY THAT THESE
ALLEGATIONS ARE I I'M HAVE BEEN
TAKEN IN.
BUT WE DO NOT DISCLOSE THE NAMES
OF THE USED SO.
WE ARE ACTUALLY GOING BEYOND
WHAT MANY PUBLIC AGENCIES ARE
DOING WITH DISCLOSURE.
AND AND I THINK THAT THAT'S
APPROPRIATE APPROPRIATE THAT
WHEN IT COMES TO MEN AND TO
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE THAT
WHEN THERE ARE SERIOUS.
SUSTAINED ALLEGATIONS THAT WE
CONTINUE OUR CURRENT POLICY THAT
WE HVE RECENTLY ESTABLISHED OF
SEND OF RELEASING THAT --
TO THE PUBLIC SO WE ARE A
CONTINUING THAT THAT PROCESS
THAT WAS SET INTO MOTION I
BELIEVE EARLIER THIS YEAR --
UPSET SO THANK YOU GO THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THAT I GO TO THE
GREAT QUESTION NUMBER.
TWO SUMMER AGAIN I SAY IT YOU
KNOW THERE PROBABLY ISN'T REAL
INDEPENDENCE BECAUSE WE'RE USING
THE LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL.
BUT WHAT I SAY THAT.
LET ME AY LET ME SAY THAT WE
ARE DESIGNING THIS IN OUR
INSTRUCTION IS THAT EVEN THOUGH
THIS BODY IS SORT OF HOUSE
UNDERNEATH THE UMBRELLA OF
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL WERE CALLING
IT THE INDEPENDENT UNIT FOR A
REASON.
THAT WE ARE DIRECTING.
THAT POLICY TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT UNIT IS SOCIETY LOADS OF
THAT INDEPENDENT COUNSEL DOES
NOT IMPACT OUR WAY ON THE
PANEL'S DECISION.
SO THAT WILL BE DONE THROUGH THE
WAY THROUGH DESIGN AND THROUGH
INSTRUCTIONS AND THAT WILL BE
THE POLICY GOING FORWARD.
SECOND I THINK YOU KNOW
FUNCTIONALLY A WE TALK ABOUT
INDEPENDENT UNIT THEY HAVE TO BE
HOUSE SOMEPLACE PAID BY SOMEBODY
REPORT I MEAN.
AND SO.
WHERE ELSE COULD THEY BE HOW
COULD THEY SERVE AND WE'VE
LOOKED AT ALL KINDS OF OPTIONS --
AND AGAIN I THINK THAT WE'VE
CREATED --
ENOUGH FIRE WALLSAND HOW'S THAT
IN THE PLACE --
THAT IS TRULY BY CAMEL ON A
LEDGE COUNCIL SERVES BOTH AND
AFTER YOU ASKWITH ALL YOUR
QUESTION I WOULD BE INTERESTED
IN TERMS OF WHAT YOUR ANSWERS
WOULD BE IN TERMS OF YOUR
PERSPECTIVE OF OF THE POLICY.
APPRECIATE YOUR DEFENSIVENESS
SIDE.
SOME OF THE DEFENSE OF ONE OF MY
ABOUT IT WE'RE ALL GOING TO BE
THAT WE'RE ALL GOING TO BE YOU
KNOW ASTON SO I I SAW GIVE YOU
THE LAST ONE OKAY BATON REALLY
ADMIT WITH SINCERE IN TERMS OF
WHAT.
I WHAT I'M HEARING ABOUT YOUR
OPINION --
INDEPENDENCE.
WHEN THE COUNTY OF ORANGE HAD
ITS IN LONG?
EPISODE IN CHAPTER WE ACTUALLY
ESTABLISHED --
PANEL BUT IT WAS --
OF INTERNAL INDIVIDUALS IT WAS
THE COUNTY COUNCIL IT WAS THE
INTERNAL AUDIT DIRECTOR AND I
CANNOT RECALL.
RIGHT NOW THE THIRD SO I AS A
SUPERVISOR THAT WAS.
ADEQUATE DID EVERY COMPLAINT
WOULD BE ADDRESSED AND THAT IT
WAS.
INDIVIDUALS REPORTING TO ME --
DIDN'T SEEM TO BE A PROBLEM
BECAUSE THEY WERE SORT OF
INDEPENDENT.
JUST IN THEIR ROLES COUNTY
COUNCIL WHO HOW ARE WHO ARGUES
WITH COUNTY COUNCIL WHO ARGUES
WITH THE INTERNAL AUDITOR.
AND AND SO I WAS COMFORTABLE.
WITH IT SO SO THAT OUR SYSTEM IS
KIND OF A DIFFERENT RELIGION
THAT THAT'S A GOOD THING YOU'RE
DOING GREAT I'M GLAD I ACTUALLY
QUITE ENJOY HERE COMES THE
TOUGHEST.
ONE OKAY.
NOW I JUST --
WHETHER OR NOT.
IT'S STILL A PROCESS THAT GIVES.
INDIVIDUALS ASSURANCE BECAUSE
IT'S STILL THE LEGISLATORS AT
THE END OF THE DAY THAT OVERSEE
LIKE I JUST SAID.
THE LEDGE COUNCIL AND WE EVEN
SELECT.
OR APPROVED CHIEF JUSTICE SO WE
STILL HAVE.
SOME KIND OF CONTROL AND SO THAT.
ALSO KIND OF MAKES A COMMENT
ABOUT INDEPENDENT I HAD HER WE
WERE MEETING THAT.
WELL THAT LEGISLATORS DON'T
WEIGH IN ON THE PANELS
DETERMINATION IT WHETHER OR NOT
THERE WAS A VIOLATION.
WHO DOES THE PUNISHMENT WELL
THAT'S WHAT THE PANEL MAKES
RECOMMENDATIONS ABOUT WHAT THE
RESPONSE WILL BE PUNISHMENT
RESPONSE HOW EVERYONE CALLED
TRAINING WHATEVER WHATEVER THEIR
RESPONSES?
AND JUST LIKE IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY THERE STILL NEEDS TO BE
SOME DISCUSSION FOR THE EMPLOYER
IN TERMS OF HOW THAT WORKS AND
AND WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE BECAUSE
THE PANEL.
THERE AND THEY'RE OUTSIDE PEOPLE
WHO COME IN TO LOOK AT THE
INDIVIDUAL SITUATION AND SAY.
WHAT YOU KNOW THEY THEY WILL
KNOW THE POLICY AND TO BE ABLE
TO MAKE THAT DETERMINATION BUT
THEY'RE ALSO NOT IN THE OFFICE
IS TO REALLY?
KIND OF NO NECESSARILY.
WHAT IS CERTAIN INDIVIDUAL DOES
DAY TODAY WHAT'S THE MOST
APPROPRIATE RESPONSE THEY CAN
MAKE A RECOMMENDATION MY GUESS
IS IN MANY CASES IT WILL BE A
FAIRLY BROAD RECOMMENDATION WE
THINK THIS WAS VERY SERIOUS I
SHOULD BE A LOT OF DISCIPLINE?
BUT THEY MAY NOT SAY AND THAT
DISCIPLINE MEANS.
YOU KNOW WHAT THIS OUT OF THE
OTHER THING A BUT FOR MEMBERS WE
DON'T WE DON'T KNOW IN MAYBE BUT
I THINK FOR MEMBERS.
YOU KNOW LET'S BE HONEST THE
MOST DISCIPLINE YOU CAN GIVE A
MATT MEMBER OF THE LEGISLATURE
IS PUBLIC DISCLOSURE.
YOU KNOW WE ARE WE CAN'T BE
FIRED.
THERE'S BEEN SOME DISCIPLINE
THAT CAN BE HANDED OUT
COMMITTEES CAN BE TAKEN AWAY YOU
CAN BE THROWN OUT OF CAUCUS AT
THE VERY END YOU COULD BE
EXPELLED FOR YOU KNOW EGREGIOUS
VIOLATIONS ALTHOUGH IT DOES NOT
DOESN'T HAPPEN VERY OFTEN.
BUT BEING ON THE FRONT PAGE OF
THE NEWSPAPER SAYING THAT YOU'VE
HAD A SUSTAINED [inaudible]
SERIOUS ALLEGATION OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT --
THAT'S VERY SERIOUS WE SAW WHAT
HAPPENED TO THE CAREERS OF SOME
OF OUR COLLEAGUES WE KNOW WHERE
THAT HAPPENED AND THAT WE WON'T
HAVE CONTROL OVER LEADERSHIP
WON'T HAVE CONTROL OVER THAT
BECAUSE OF OUR POLICY SAYS.
THAT WE WILL RELEASE THAT
DETERMINATION IF IT'S FOUND TO
BEAT TO HAVE OCCURRED. TO THE
MEDIA.
SO ALREADY YOU'VE TAKEN.
THE ROLE OF LEADERSHIP MAKING
THAT DECISION OUT OF THEIR HANDS
WE'RE GIVING THAT NOW FOR THE
FIRST TIME TO AN INDEPENDENT
PANEL TO DECIDE AND THAT'S A
HUGE CHANGE.
HUGE AND THAT IS WITHOUT.
BUT THAT THAT IS --
IT DID YOU KNOW THAT IS --
I THINK.
OUT OF IT WILL BE CERTAINLY OUT
OF THE HANDS OF THE COLLEAGUES
OF THE LEGISLATORS TO MAKE THAT
DETERMINATION IT WILL BE UP TO
THE PANEL. TO DO THAT BUT BY OUR
POLICY THAT WE'VE THAT WE'VE
STATED AND WE CANNOT OWE YOU
KNOW OVER STATE I THINK THE
GRAVITY OF THAT AND I DON'T
THINK THAT'S GOING TO BE LOST ON
ANY OF OUR COLLEAGUES AND YOU
KNOW THAT'S DIFFERENT FOR MAYBE
WHAT.
HAPPENED I DON'T KNOW I WASN'T
HERE.
BUT THAT'S THAT'S NEW IS FAR AS
I CAN SEE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRS GOOD JOB
[inaudible]
YES. TO I THAT'S WHY I THINK
IT'S VERY CRITICAL THAT THAT.
THAT BY PERSON BODY IS VERY.
INDEPENDENT SO THAT.
SO THAT WE HAVE --
NON PART THAT'S THE KEY TO THIS
WHOLE THING IN MY MIND THE KEY
TO THIS IS THAT WE HAVE FAITH.
AND TRUST IN THAT PANEL.
THAT WHATEVER THE OUTCOME IS IS
A IS JUSTICE AT IT IT'S RIGHT SO
THAT'S WHY I BROUGHT UP FOR AND
I THINK THAT'S THE KEY TO THIS
WHOLE THING IS THAT.
IF YOU'RE PANEL IS.
STRUCTURED IN A WAY WHERE IT IS
TRULY NOT THERE'S NO WAY THAT
THIS SCALE CAN BE.
DONE CAN BE ON THE SCALE IN ANY
DIRECTION THAN THAT THAT IT THAT
WE'RE GOING TO GET SOMEWHERE I
THINK IN A POSITIVE PLACE.
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIGHT AYE WE
YOU KNOW WILL.
LOOK TO CONTINUE TO ADJUST THE
LANGUAGE AS WE TAKE THAT POLICY
FORWARD ON MONDAY AND SO I THINK
IT'S IT'S TWO THINGS --
IT'S THE ISSUE OF ON NON
PARTISANSHIP.
AND I THINK ALL OF US ARE GOING
TO HAVE TO COLLECTIVELY ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE ABOUT WHETHER WE CAN
BE PROFESSIONALENOUGH THAT HAVE
THE CAPACITY. TO FOLLOW THE
RECOMMENDATIONS.
OF THE PANEL --
AND AND POLICE ARE SELF SENATOR
MORE LOCKING LIVING EXAMPLE --
OF WHEN IT WAS INTERNAL
EMPLOYEES IF YOU WILL WHO SERVED
ON THAT PANEL AND SO I THINK
IT'S TWO THINGS THAT WE LEAVE.
I WOULD HOPE WILL PUSH BACK --
TO THOSE WHO SAY THEY WANT A
TRULY INDEPENDENT AND I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS.
IN A WORKPLACE AND SO.
NONPARTISAN I HEAR YOU AND I GET
IT I THINK THAT WE HAVE TO
ADDRESS BOTH OF THOSE.
CONCERNS.
I HAVE ABSOLUTELY I AGREE AND
I'M ALL THIS JUST TO CLARIFY
BECAUSE THERE'S TWO DIFFERENT
THINGS THE PANEL DOES ONE IS TO
MAKE A DETERMINATION IF THERE'S
BEEN A VIOLATION OF POLICY.
THAT'S WHAT IF THIS IS SERIOUS --
AND UP SUBSTANTIATED A VIOLATION
OF OUR SEXUAL HARASSMENT POLICY
THAT'S WHAT WOULD BE RELEASED TO
THE PUBLIC.
THE RECOMMENDATION IS DIFFERENT
THAT YOU KNOW WE ARE NOT
ANTICIPATING RELEASING THAT TO
THE PUBLIC --
THAT'S WHERE WE DO HAVE TO HAVE
THE DISCIPLINE TO TO BE ABLE TO
POLICE OURSELVES AND TO MAKE
THAT DETERMINATION AS AN
EMPLOYER.
SO I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY THAT
POINT.
THEN JUST WANT CLARIFICATION IN
THAT IS WITH POINT ONE ARE
DEALING WITH LOBBYISTS DID DODO
WE FEEL COMFORTABLE ENOUGH THAT.
IT'S BECAUSE WE CANNOT
DISCIPLINE LOBBYIST OTHER THAN.
WE KNOW DISCLOSING THAT THEY'VE
BEEN INVESTIGATING.
UMBER AB ARE YOU COMFORTABLE
WITH WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE TO
ADDRESS.
BECAUSE I WAS CONFUSED AS
ASSEMBLY WOMAN REYES WAS THAT.
WE WE HAVE.
THAT ONE CATEGORY OF LOBBYISTS
AND OTHER AND WAS A LITTLE
DIFFICULT TO UNDERSTAND.
SURVEY THANK YOU AND THAT'S A A
VERY FAIR QUESTION I THINK THAT
WE STILL HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO
DO TO DETERMINE.
WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE WHEN IT
COMES TO ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC I WILL SAY THAT WE HAVE
AN AFFIRMATIVE DUTY IF WE HAVE A
CO IF WE FIND OUT OF FOR TOLD
THAT ONE OF OUR EMPLOYEES IS
SUBJECT?
TO SEXUAL HARASSMENT OR OTHER
TYPES OF OF SERIOUS ABUSE FROM
ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC TO
PROTECT THEM AND WE CAN'T DO
THAT WITHOUT WANTING SOME KIND
OF INVESTIGATION.
SO IT WE WILL HAVE TO
INVESTIGATE THAT SHOULD BE DOING
THAT NOW AND I DO THINK THAT IN
SOME CASES WE DO DO THAT.
WHEN SOMEONE COMPLAINS OF
SOMEONE THAT THEY'RE IN CONTACT
CONSTANT CONTACT WITH THROUGH
THEIR WORK IS AS HARASSED
SEXUALLY HARASSING THEM?
IN TERMS OF IN TERMS OF THE REST
OF OUR POLICY THAT.
OTHER CONDUCT TOWARDS OTHERS
CLEARLY WE CAN'T EXTEND THAT TO
A CONSTITUENT COUNTABLE FIELD.
SO WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO KIND OF
FIGURE OUT WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE
AND IT WILL PROBABLY BE A LITTLE
BIT DIFFERENT FOR PEOPLE WHO
WERE IN THE BUILDING AT EVERY
DAY BECAUSE IT'S THEIR JOB BEING
THERE ARE LOBBYISTS.
ON AND JUST MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC BUT I WANT TO KNOW IF MY
IF ONE OF MY FIELD
REPRESENTATIVES.
FINDS THAT THEY'RE CONSTANTLY IN
A SITUATION THAT THAT THEY THINK
IS DANGEROUS ARE UNCOMFORTABLE
AND IN IN THAT PERFORMANCE OF
THEIR WORK --
WHEN THEY'REOUT IN THE FIELDS I
WANT THEM TO HAVE A BEEN PLEASED
TO REPORT THAT AND WE NEED TO
TAKE SOME ACTION TO PROTECT THEM
WHETHER IT'S SAYING THAT WE'RE
NOT GOING?
TO HAVE A PUBLIC EVENT WITH THAT
INDIVIDUAL OR OR WHATEVER IT IS
BUT WE HAVE THAT THAT
RESPONSIBILITY AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WILL FIGURE OUT
AS WE MOVE THIS POLICY FORWARD.
OKAY AMERICA FOR THE COLLEGE
TIME I'M SORRY SENATOR LEYVA.
BE SORRY THIS IS JUST A QUICK
COMMENT -- I
I JUST I WILL I TO WANT TO THINK
AGAIN AND THE CHAIR AND THE VICE
CHAIR BUT I THINK THAT SENATOR
MITCHELL YOU REALLY HIT THE NAIL
ON THE HEAD THIS IS AN HR MATTER.
AND WE CAN'T OVER FORGET THAT
COMPANIES HAVE HR DEPARTMENTS
THAT ARE PAID.
FOR BY THAT COMPANY BAND THERE
IS REALLY NO WAY FOR US TO BE
COMPLETELY INDEPENDENT WHO WOULD
THATPERSON BE.
I'M INCREDIBLY IMPRESSED WITH
THE WORK OF THIS COMMITTEE WE
STARTED OUT A LITTLE ROCKY I
WASN'T SURE WHERE WE'RE GONNA
END UP.
BUT THIS IS A BIG SEA CHANGE AND
I THINK THAT WE HAVE COME TO
SOME REALLY GREAT FOR
CONCLUSIONS WE'VE COME TO A
POLICY I THINK IS VERY WORKABLE
DOABLE.
AND IS GOING TO PROTECT EVERYONE
WHO WORKS IN THIS BUILDING SO I
THINK MOVING FORWARD.
IT WILL PLAY ALSO BE A LITTLE
ROCKY ONLY BECAUSE IT'S SUCH A
BIG SEA CHANGE BUT EVERYONE HAS
COME TOGETHER AND WORK VERY HARD
ON THIS SO I THINK YOU AND I
JUST.
HOPE THAT WE ALL REMEMBER WE'RE
IN THIS FOR THE RIGHT REASONS
WERE IN THIS TO PROTECT THOSE
THAT WE WORK WITH.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
AND ACTUALLY AND I DO WANT TO
JUST PIGGYBACK ON THAT BECAUSE
YOU MENTIONED OUR INTERNAL.
ON HR DEPARTMENT WHICH IS UNDER
OUR RULES DEPARTMENT WE HAVE
EXTREMELYPROFESSIONAL HR PEOPLE
IN OUR RULES DEPARTMENTS IN ANY
FAILURE THAT THERE HAS BEEN ARE
PERCEIVED TO HAS BEEN.
IT'S NOT BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
PROFESSIONAL PEOPLE IT'S BECAUSE
OUR POLICY WHICH IS A TOP DOWN
POLICY HAS ALLOWED FOR THOSE
FAILURES.
THE SAME INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE IN
OUR RULES DEPARTMENT ARE
CERTAINLY VERY CAPABLE OF
ADMINISTERING THIS POLICY.
AND I WOULD LOVE TO SEE MORE
PEOPLE LIKE THAT YOU KNOW AS WE
CAN TO THE FLESH THIS OUT YOU
KNOW WE HAVE THESE GREAT HR
PEOPLE I'D LOVE TO SEE.
OVER TIME THAT WE HAVE MORE OF
THESE PROFESSIONAL HR PEOPLE --
OUT THERE TO SUPPORT OUR STUFF
AND I KNOW THAT --
THE PEOPLE THAT WE HAVE ARE
GOING TO BE.
YOU KNOW ARE VERY FAIR AND
HIGHLY TRAINED IN THE CAN
CERTAINLY ADMINISTER THE POLICY --
WE HAVE --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RADIUS.
AND FOLLOWED BY DAILY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I I JUST
WANT.
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE WHO I I
THINK WE DID WE'VE JUST TO
SENATOR LABOR HAS INDICATED.
WHICH IS A GOOD JOB.
WE DID START OUT A LITTLE ROCKY
BUT I I I THE WORK THAT WE'VE
DONE.
IN A BIPARTISAN BICAMERAL WAY --
AND I APPRECIAE THE FACT THAT
AT THE LAST HEARING YOU HEARD
OUR COMMENTS AND YOU INCLUDED
THOSE AS POTENTIAL REVISIONS TO
THE POLICY THAT HAD ALREADY BEEN
PUT INTO TO AFFECT.
WE'RE LOOKING TO CHANGE THE
CULTURE IN THE CAPITAL.
IT TOOK A LONG TIME TO GET TO
WHERE WE ARE TODAY AND IT'S
GOING TO TAKE A LONG TIME. TO
GET IT TO WHERE WE WANT IT TO BE --
AYE BUT I DO APPRECIATE ALL THAT
THE TO DONE MADAM CHAIR MADAM
VICE CHAIR --
AND ALL OF THE STAFF THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
THANK YOU SO MEMBER DALY SO NO.
I JUST WANT TO ASK FOR THE
PROCESS FROM HERE FORWARD SO I
WON IT SO --
THESE IT WE'VE HAD.
I THINK PRETTY MUCH WE HAVE.
AGREEMENT ON AT LEAST FOUR OF
THE GOOD THINGS THAT WERE LISTED
OUT HERE WE HAVE AN AMENDMENT
FROM --
SENATOR BATES IN THAT WE HAVE A
QUESTION ON THREE OF HOW WE'RE
GOING TO DO THE POINT SO WHAT'S
THE PROCESS GOING FORWARD.
THANK YOU SO THE FIRST STEP
AFTER WE'VE MADE OUR COMMENTS AS
WE HAVE THE PUBLIC --
AS A PUBLIC IF THEY WOULD LIKE
TO TO SPEAK AND THEN WE WILL
VOTE TO SEND THE RECOMMENDATIONS
ALONG WITH THE CONSIDERATIONS OF
THE ISSUES THAT YOU BROUGHT UP.
SEND THAT FOR JOINT RULES IS
CONSIDERATION ALONG WITH THE
AMENDMENT THAT YOU THAT THAT WAS
SUBMITTED TO US FOR JOINT RULES --
TO CONSIDER.
BECAUSE I THINK YOU'VE SEEN SOME
OF THE ISSUES THAT COME UP --
ON HAVE IT JUST COME UP TODAY
AND SO WE NEED DO NEED TO HAVE
TIME TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
LEADERS OF BOTH HOUSES HAVE HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO WEIGH IN.
ON AND SO I THINK SINCE WE HAVE
BEEN MEETING ON MONDAY ALL OF
THOSE FACTS ALL OF THOSE ISSUES
CAN BE.
YOU KNOW WE COULD PUT SOME MEAT
ON THOSE BONES AND CAN BE
CLARIFIED.
ON AS WE PRESENT ON MONDAY SAY.
SAY THAT THERE IS A DISCREPANCY
BETWEEN THE HOUSES ECAUSE
THEY'D THEY OPERATE DIFFERENT
SAY THAT ONE HOUSE DECIDES THAT
IT'S OKAY THE OTHER HOUSE
DOESN'T LIKE IT.
WHAT WOULD BE THE PROCESS FOR
GOING FORWARD HE PROCESS THAT
WE'VE USED UP TO THIS POINT WE
CONTINGENT AGO SHEET WE BRING
AND --
LEADERS WHICH INCLUDE YOURSELF
OF THE MINORITY LEADER FOR THE
FAMILY TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON
UNTIL WE GET SOME LANGUAGE THAT
WE CAN AGREE WITH THAT'S THE
PROCESS WE FEW LIES UP TO THIS
POINT.
AWESOME THAT'S WHAT I WANT BUT I
JUST WANNA I WANNA FINISH STRONG
TO AND I THINK THAT WE HAVE.
VERY MUCH --
WE HAVE COVERED A LOT OF GROUND
AND IN THEIR SOME DETAILS THAT I
THINK WILL MAKE IT REALLY STRONG
AND VERY HELPFUL.
FOR NO THE BIGGEST --
CONCERN I HAVE IS THAT THERE ARE
STILL EMPLOYEES OUT THERE WHO.
DON'T HAVE A PROCESS THAT THEY
FEEL COMFORTABLE WITH THAT WE'RE
GETTING TOWARDS OUT I KNOW IT.
I KNOW IT DOWN YOU KNOW WE HAVE.
ALL THE TIME IN THE WORLD TO DO
IT RIGHT AND WE HAVE NO TIME TO
DO A WRONG BECAUSE THERE'S THERE
WAITING ANOTHER SOME OUT THERE
THAT ARE WAITING FOR PROCESS
THAT IS IS.
GOOD AND PROPER AND SO ON IF WE
IF WE HAVE THE ABILITY MOVING
FORWARD.
TO WORK OUT THE FEW THAT I THINK
WE HAVE JUST MINOR THINGS AT
THIS POINT REALLY I THINK WERE
ALL TRYING TO GET TO THE RIGHT
PLACE SO I'M EXCITED ABOUT THAT
SO WHEN THEY'RE IF THERE.
IS A TIME I WOULD BE HAPPY TO
MAKE A MOTION OR WHATEVER YOU
WOULD LIKE THAT MADAM CHAIR
AFTER PUBLIC COMMENT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
A SOME MEMBER WALDRON.
JUST REALLY BRIEFED BRIEFLY --
THANK YOU SO MUCH TO THE CHAIRS
FOR YOUR HARD WORK ON THAT --
THIS WHOLE COMMITTEE REALLY
STUCK WITH IT WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT WHERE WE STARTED OFF WITH
ALL THE EMOTION AND THE YOU KNOW
THE CROWDED MEETINGS AND ALL THE
MEDIA AND EVERYTHING ESE THAT
WAS GOING ON YOU KNOW TRYING.
TO TAKE ALL OF THAT AND FOCUS IT
DOWN INTO SOMETHNG THAT IS
REALLY.
A WORKABLE SOLUTION THAT YOU
KNOW WE WILL CONTINUE HAS TO
CONTINUE AS THIS YOU KNOW MOVES
AHEAD.
THINGS WILL SURFACE AND AS WE
HEARD EVEN IN THE BEGINNING OF
THE WEEK ONE OF THE THINGS WE
MIGHT WANT TO CONSIDER IS COME
BACK AND WE DO THE SURVEY AND
YOU KNOW SIX MONTHS OR EIGHT
MONTHS OF WHATEVER SO WE CAN SEE.
YOU KNOW.
WHAT IMPACT IT HAS HAD AT THAT
POINT -- IT
WILL NO GOING FORWARD IN YOU
KNOW THIS COMMITTEE WOULD
PROBABLY HAVE TO RECONVENE AGAIN
AT SOME POINT AND CONTINUE. TO
LOOK AT SOME OF THOSE SO I'M
ENCOURAGED BY.
WHERE WE'VE GOTTEN TO I'M
ENCOURAGED BY?
YOU KNOW THE FACT THAT WE COULD
ALL PUT IN AND THAT WE CAN STILL
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THE FINE
POINTS AND MAKE SOMETHING THAT
IS REALLY WORKABLE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU YOU PUT PUBLIC COMMENT
YES THINK SENATOR MEDICALLY OPEN
TO PUBLIC COMMENT I JUST WANTED
TO SAY THAT AS AS WE RECALL THE
CLIMATE.
OF SERVING WE TALK ABOUT I TALK
ABOUT THE BELL CURVE AND THE
PROMOTER.
YOU MISTER DALI FOR OUR STAFFS
TO FEEL COMFORTABLE WITH THIS
NEW POLICY WE'RE ALL GONNA HAVE
TO AGREE TO BE PROMOTERS --
TO TO GO ABOVE AND BEYOND
CONGRATULATE EACH OTHER FOR OUR
HARD WORK BUT TO TALK TO OUR
STAFF -- WE
ARE THERE MOST ARE THERE --
CLOSEST CONNECTION TO
UNDERSTANDING WHAT IT MEANS TO
BE AN EMPLOYEE OF THE
LEGISLATURE SO IF WE ALL AGREE
TO BE PROMOTERS TO TALK ABOUT
OUR CONFIDENCE IN THIS POLICY.
THAT WILL GO FAR IN TERMS OF
EMPLOYEES FEELING COMFORTABLE TO
COME FORWARD BECAUSE THEY'VE
HEARD FROM US GOOD WE'VE ALL
AGREED TO BE ON THE PROMOTER
SIDE OF THAT BELL CURVE.
IN TERMS OF MAKING SURE THAT
PEOPLE NDERSTAND THIS POLICY
THE SOUND WE HAVE EVERY
CONFIDENCE IN IT IT'S BICAMERAL.
WHAT'S IN THEIR BEST INTEREST
OKAY IF THERE'S NO MORE COMMENTS
AT THIS TIME WILL TURN TO A
PUBLIC COMMENT IS ARE ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO WOULD
LIKE.
TO MAKE ANY COMMENTS IT SO
PLEASE COME TO THE MIKE
[inaudible]
AS IT IT IT'S FINE.
THANK YOU I'M JIM WHEN BURKE ON
BEHALF OF THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION TO CALIFORNIA AND
I WILL JUST REITERATE THAT I'M.
VERY IMPRESSED --
WITH THIS WORK IT'S BEEN --
PRODUCED AND THE RECOGNITION
THAT --
CULTURE ALWAYS TRUMP'S POLICY
AND THAT WE REALLY NEED TO FOCUS
ON A CULTURAL CHANGE --
EARLIER THIS SPRING OF THE
COMMITTEE HEARD FROM DOCTORFINE
YET DAVIS --
FROM RESTORATIVE JUSTICE OAKLAND
YOUTH AND SHE SPOKE ABOUT THE
TRANSFER VALUE OF RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE --
ESPECIALLY WHEN DEALING WITH
BEHAVIOR.
THAT DOESN'T NECESSARILY RISE TO
THE LEVEL OF CRIMINAL CONDUCT
BUT IS NEVERTHELESS HIGHLY
INAPPROPRIATE AND DEMANDS A
RESPONSE --
DOCTOR DAVID CITED A CASE STUDY
FROM DOW HOUSE THE UNIVERSITY IN
CANADA --
WHICH IMPLEMENTED A RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE RESPONSE TO SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AND SEXUAL MISCONDUCT --
THE WOMEN WHO WEAR THE
RECIPIENTS OF THE INAPPROPRIATE
CONDUCT --
REPORTED A VERY HIGH DEGREE OF
SATISFACTION AFTER PARTICIPATING
IN IN THESE RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
ENCOUNTERS.
WE HAVE HEARD REPEATEDLY ON OUR
WORK A ABOUT HOW IMPORTANT AND
MEANINGFUL IT IS FOR VICTIMS TO
HAVE.
THEIR HARM AND SUFFERING.
VALIDATED AND ACKNOWLEDGED --
BY THE AGGRESSOR AND TO BE ABLE
TO PARTICIPATE AND AND AND
CONSTRUCTING.
THE REMEDY --
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE IS ALWAYS
OPTIONAL --
WE THINK IT SHOULD BE AN OPTION
FOR THOSE WHO WOULD LIKE A THAT
AS AN ALTERNATIVE OUR HOPE IS
THAT MOVING FORWARD THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WILL FORMALLY
RECOGNIZE IT AS AN ALTERNATIVE
AND CREATE A STRUCTURE WHERE
COULD BE PUT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
WITHOUT IT THERE'S NO FINAL
COMMENTS WE DO HAVE A MOTION
FROM MISTER DALY ALL SECOND AND
SENATOR MITCHELL HAS SECONDED --
WITH THAT WE HAVE A ROLL CALL
PLEASE.
SENATOR FOR ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN.
AYE FRIEDMAN AYE DOLLY.
DOLLY I REYES AYE FREAS AYE
WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE SENATOR MITCHELL AYE
CENTER MITCHELL AYE BATES.
BATES AYE LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE WARLOCK.
MORE LIKE I WITH THAT WE HAVE
UNANIMOUSLY.
ADOPTED THE RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
THE FRAMEWORK PARTNER SEXUAL
HARASSMENT PREVENTION AND
RESPONSE POLICIES WE WILL BE
SENDING THEM TO JOINT RULES
WHICH WILL MEET ON MONDAY.
AGAIN I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL
FOR YOUR WORK AND WITHOUT THE
HEARING IS ADJOURNED